FEMALE SPEAKER: Hi folks, thanks
so much for being here today.
Talks at Google is excited
to welcome Hillary, Deuki,
and Matt here today.
I'm just going to do a
quick little intro of them
and let them do their thing.
Hillary right over here is
Eater.com's Senior Reports
Editor, where she
writes and edits
stories that track where the
restaurant industry intersects
with national trends,
public policy, science
technology, and pop culture.
She joined Eater in 2013
after working her way up
through the New York
City restaurant scene.
A New Jersey
native, she recently
relocated to San
Francisco from Brooklyn.
And she's enjoying
the better weather.
Shh, don't ever say
anything about the weather,
you'll spook it.
This is Deuki Hong.
At 15, Hong worked
as a line cook
under Aaron Sanchez of
Centrico, New York City.
Is that legal, Deuki?
Is that legal?
DEUKI HONG: I don't think so,
we should edit that one out.
FEMALE SPEAKER: 15 and
a half, New York City,
before heading to the
Culinary Institute of America.
After graduating near
the top of his class,
he cooked under David Chang
at Momofuku Noodle Bar
before two years
in line at Michelin
three-starred Jean-Georges.
A young-- I'm probably
mispronouncing it--
rising star chef, Hong is
currently Executive Chef
of the smash hit, Kang Ho Dong--
DEUKI HONG: Baekjong.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
In Manhattan's Koreatown.
He's recently been recognized
as an Eater young gun
and named to the "Zagat"
30 under 30 list.
MATT RODBARD: That's Google!
DEUKI HONG: Shout out!
MATT RODBARD: Yes it is.
DEUKI HONG: Thank you Google.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yes.
And this is Matt Rodbard.
For over a decade-- uh
oh, your [INAUDIBLE]
is showing if you do that.
Rodbard has written
magazine and online features
about restaurants, shops,
drinks, music, cooking,
and travel.
His writing has appeared in "Bon
Appetit," "Travel and Leisure,"
"Saveur," "Men's Journal,"
"Fodors," and "Tasting Table."
And he currently serves
as a Contributing Editor
at "Food Republic."
MATT RODBARD: Thank
you for having us.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thanks
so much for being here.
MATT RODBARD: Well
I appreciate it.
And I want to just tap the
audience right here before we
get into the conversation.
So how many of you
have that have cooked
Korean food in the last week.
Anybody?
Oh and this session
is streaming too,
so raise your hand at your desk.
DEUKI HONG: Is this live?
This is so cool.
MATT RODBARD: And so
many of you have actually
have just gone to a
restaurant Korean restaurant
in the last week?
That's awesome.
So there's definitely
a lot of people
who have had Korean food.
And I just wanted to see what
kind of crowd we have here.
There you go.
Yeah.
DEUKI HONG: Past stragglers.
HILLARY: So we'll
have time for Q & A,
but if you have any
pressing questions
as we're having
our conversation,
please feel free to shoot
a hand up and just ask us.
But I just want to dive right
in and ask what is Koreatown.
MATT RODBARD: It's
a good question.
Well first off thank you
for having us Google.
It's a huge honor to be talking
about Korean food to this room
and to the masses.
So really appreciate that.
And thank you Hillary
for moderating.
DEUKI HONG: Thanks [INAUDIBLE].
MATT RODBARD: I've been a fan
of your writing for a long time.
So thank you for
taking the time.
HILLARY: Vice versa.
MATT RODBARD: Absolutely.
But Koreatown is really--
it's a place of course.
There's Koreatowns
in most cities.
But the way you really
think about Koreatown,
it's a mentality.
You put two Korean markets
next to a Korean dry cleaner
next to a Korean restaurant
and you've got a Koreatown.
That is everywhere.
DEUKI HONG: At least
that's how we defined it.
It's just very like--
MATT RODBARD: It's
not like-- you
don't need 50,000 Koreans in
an area for it to be Koreatown.
We found Koreatowns
through our travels
over the course of the research
of this book, which was
about three and a half years.
We found Koreatowns
in the expected
places like New
York, where we live,
and Los Angeles, which is the
biggest Koreatown in America.
But we also found in places
like north Philadelphia
and outside Chicago,
Minneapolis, Houston.
Places that may be
aren't considered
the Koreatown
epicenter of America.
But really Koreatown
is more of a spirit.
Right?
We talk about that a
lot when we're out.
We talk Korean food.
DEUKI HONG: I mean we
had to define it first
before we found it.
I mean to his credit, it was
Matty that wrote the book--I
mean not wrote the book, that
came up with the whole concept
of Koreatown.
I remember asking him,
so what are we doing.
And we had to define it.
And I think that's
how we defined it.
Was really the mentality.
You know, like you said, if
you saw two Korean restaurants
next to each other or we were
just in Madison, Wisconsin,
an adopted Korean chef has
just a Korean restaurant
in the middle of
Madison, Wisconsin.
That embodies really Koreatown.
MATT RODBARD: That's
Koreatown right there.
And we'll get into
other parts of Koreatown
through the conversation which
may be a little unexpected too.
HILLARY: Yeah, for sure.
So for people who haven't got it
chance to open their books yet,
one of the really unusual
things about the presentation
and the structure
of this book is
that there's a pretty typical
cookbook structure, especially
cookbooks that are tied to
restaurant chefs like Deuki.
Where it's got an intro, and
you have a recipe header where
it's usually a story about
why this dish is meaningful,
the story of the dish
ended up on the menu.
You have the recipe
and then either
on the left side
or the right side
will be a picture of the dish.
And that is not what your
guys' book looks like.
And how does the structure
of the book to you
reflect that Koreatown spirit.
MATT RODBARD: It's
a really good point.
When we signed our
contract, we really
didn't know what we were doing.
We aren't cookbook authors.
Are you not a cookbook
chef or a recipe developer.
I knew magazine.
I knew web journalism.
I knew packaging.
And I really wanted
us to do a book that
brought the energy and
spirit of Koreatown to life.
So to do that we
needed to look outward.
It wasn't just repeating
recipes from your family
and from our friends.
We had to go out and
actually find them.
And you see that in the
structure of the book
as we were reporting.
We like to think that we
went and talked to people
and ran the recorder
and ran our iPhones
and talked for several
hours and went back
to those conversations and
figured out a story from then.
That's kind of the way we look
at the Koreatown as a book.
As more of cultural
anthropology of sorts.
You know, it's not just
the recipe, head note,
circle plate, circle
plate, circle plate, photo
that you see in a
lot of cookbooks.
Nothing against circle plates.
DEUKI HONG: We
have circle plates.
MATT RODBARD: We do
have some circle plates.
But if you look
visually at the book,
it has all these
elements of travel.
And we committed the
time and resources
to travel to answer
the question, what
is Koreatown both visually
and through the recipes.
It's not the easiest
way to do a cookbook.
DEUKI HONG: I mean we just
don't know what to do.
We really didn't know
what we were doing.
I think it's great that it's
not like Deuki's 101 Recipes
or Korean Cooking
Like Made Simple.
Like we didn't know
what we were doing.
MATT RODBARD: Yeah.
DEUKI HONG: And I think
out of that naivete--
which is a big word.
MATT RODBARD: Good job, Chef.
DEUKI HONG: Thank you.
We just did it like for us.
Our approach was-- he has
a magazine background.
So if you see the layout,
there's like stories in it,
there's a Q&A in there.
So I personally love the layout.
I just think, I
think I love my book.
MATT RODBARD: Yeah.
DEUKI HONG: But you know
it's just fun to read.
And I like that it's not
like stews, and then barbecue
and you know.
For me, that's kind
of the biggest draw.
We have a respect section
at the end of the book which
is a lot of really awesome chefs
that just love Korean food,
support Korean food.
That's like my favorite
section of the book.
And like how you guys
would cook food--
we made the book like that.
We went to H-mart.
MATT RODBARD: H-Mart,
which is like one
of the main Korean
markets in the east coast.
DEUKI HONG: H-Mart, went to my
apartment and started cooking.
That's literally how those
recipes have been developed.
MATT RODBARD: It's true.
DEUKI HONG: It's very raw.
HILLARY: So speaking more to
the recipe development process,
I'd love to get into the
nuts and bolts of how
this book came together.
You guys have spoken
a lot about this sort
of like going in blind.
How did the book
deal come about?
And how did you
start dividing up
the labor between yourselves?
MATT RODBARD: Good question.
Well we met actually
working on a separate book.
A smaller guidebook to Korean
restaurants in New York.
We went to 75
Korean restaurants.
Yeah you were like, whoa.
And you know, what most
of them are not very good.
DEUKI HONG: That's not nice.
MATT RODBARD: I
know it's not nice.
All right, some of them
were not very good.
We were tasked with going
to a lot of different styles
of restaurants.
And it wasn't just
the greatest hits.
There was definitely some
out-of-the-way places.
And we met through
that project where
we had to really define
these restaurants.
We rated them, as if we
were in the Michelin Guide.
We had to go in like
check off a bunch of boxes
and rate these restaurants.
And really we met
through that process.
And we came to the
conclusion that there is not
a book written from the
point of view of Koreatown.
I bought every book I
could when I was writing
that small guidebook
and I saw they
were written from the point of
a food professor from Korea.
Or from a YouTube star.
Maangchi.
She's great.
And we love Maangchi.
I've watched hundreds
hours of Maangchi
while researching Korean food.
But we aren't Maangchi.
We are more, as we said
before, journalists and chef.
So we realized there
wasn't this book written.
So what do you do.
Well, you kind of have
to write a book proposal.
And that's really what we did.
And we found, through our
great agent Angela Miller,
a home at Clarkson Potter.
Clarkson Potter is
a place that has
done a lot of big name celebrity
chefs and some smaller titles
as well.
But it was fortunate
that our book proposal
landed on the desk of Francis
Lam, who Is out editor.
And it was the
first book he signed
when he joined Clarkson Potter.
And he really he shepherded
it through from the proposal
phase all the way to the end.
And you know I think
Francis was a big part of--
DEUKI HONG: Yeah, FL's great.
I mean he's great just
because he's Francis.
And the fact that we
were his first-- we're
like the proverbial nobodies.
And for him, he could
have gotten a deal
from-- he can choose whatever
chef he wants to work with.
Whatever writer or
whatever personality
he wants to work with.
And he really believed
in the project.
And I think because he
believed in it-- like we always
believed in it because we
can just toot our own horns
because we're so awesome.
And when you get somebody like
Francis, like this is awesome.
Then you start
really believing it
and then I think
that becomes passion.
That becomes, OK, we
can go to that city.
And that kind of gets me going.
Like, FL is kind of like
my like spirit animal.
It's like, hey,
he believes in us.
HILLARY: And that's what
an editor does, right?
MATT RODBARD: He does.
He sees it through.
And he shows that he's
committed to our idea.
And I'll say, we didn't
have a million offers.
We had multiple offers.
But we didn't have
a million offers.
DEUKI HONG: And
we had two offers.
MATT RODBARD: Yeah
we had a few offers.
DEUKI HONG: Two.
MATT RODBARD: And you know
it was honestly something
that we give credit to Francis
for seeing Korean food's
rise maybe two or
three years ago,
when he signed the contracts.
HILLARY: So I want to go back
to some cookbook contacts.
When you look at the
cover of a cookbook,
including the Koreatown cookbook
that you have in front of you,
the way that the
authorship is built
is very coded with meaning.
So this book could
have been Deuki Hong
with Matt Rodbard-- could
have been the way it ended up.
It could have just
said Deuki Hong
and then maybe somewhere
inside the book
it would have explained
that Matt existed.
Sometimes chef-driven
cookbooks don't
have a writer listed anywhere.
And it's an industry secret,
you know who worked on it.
And your guys'
cookbook-- flat out you
guys are on the same level.
It says Deuki Hong
and Matt Rodbard.
Can you explain a
little bit about what
that means, both symbolically
and like practically speaking?
MATT RODBARD: We are a team.
It really means that.
We could not write this
book without each other.
It's truly the best
kind of partnership.
I'm not a hired gun
to write cookbooks.
And as you said, Deuki is
not like a celebrity TV chef.
So we both needed each other.
I need you.
I needed to ask you
a million questions.
DEUKI HONG: I wasn't
your first choice.
I'm just saying.
Just wanted to
throw it out there.
MATT RODBARD: Any ways.
Whatever.
DEUKI HONG: And
just to go on that.
I think a lot of
people get confused
because it is a Korean book.
Or Koreatown book.
They think the Korean guy on the
project kind of spearheaded it.
This is all his brainchild.
And I just kind of
hopped on and I was like,
oh yeah dude, that's awesome.
What do you need from me.
You know, he's not Korean
if you didn't realize.
He is pretty much Korean.
But for us-- and we said in
the earlier conversation--
we're friends also.
MATT RODBARD: Yeah it's true.
DEUKI HONG: We're not like,
we don't clock in and be like,
all right, let's do this event.
We talk.
We talk outside stuff.
And we've developed
a friendship.
We traveled for
two years together.
Even if you hate
each other, it's just
out of like that relationship.
And I think that genuine
friendship kind of gives it
a better product.
I didn't want to disappoint him.
Hopefully he didn't
want to disappoint me.
MATT RODBARD: Yeah.
DEUKI HONG: There was
that mutual respect.
MATT RODBARD: We didn't want
to disappoint our publisher.
And we didn't want
to disappoint--
DEUKI HONG: It was
just a lot of that.
MATT RODBARD: Korean-Americans.
Koreans who-- and we'll
talk about the food.
The food is so important
and we didn't really--
we needed to make sure we got
the right recipes in there.
We wanted to make sure we got
the right head notes in there.
And that each of these recipes
had the story it really exists.
DEUKI HONG: This book
wasn't about Deuki or Matt.
So it didn't matter what name.
Obviously nobody in this
room knows-- except my friend
over there-- which is great.
Which is fine.
Which is awesome because
it's really about the story.
It's really about
what we want to tell
or the story we want to tell.
And we always kind
of went back to that.
You won't see our faces
except in our intro.
like plastered on this book.
Nor should it be.
MATT RODBARD: Yeah.
DEUKI HONG: So it's our baby.
You can approach it.
MATT RODBARD: Any questions
at all in the audience?
There you go.
DEUKI HONG: It's like
a little study group.
Don't even-- get
a little intimate.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to
hear a little more about--
MATT RODBARD: So
the first question
was, how did we come
together for that 75 project.
And I'm reflecting on my answer
and I was a little harsh.
I did not go to mostly
bad restaurants,
I think that came
out very incorrectly.
We went to a lot of
very good restaurants.
We've been in
California for so long
that the food in
California is so good.
The Korean food here is amazing.
So that's why I've got
a little hate towards.
But I do love New York.
So anyone in New York,
there are restaurants there
that are very good.
So we met on the project.
It was funded by the
Korean government
by the Korean Food Foundation.
And they had that kind of vision
to create this guidebook, which
was naming 35, 40 of the
best Korean restaurants.
We met each other
through just dialog.
Through talking
about our results.
We had this big meeting where
we went over the results
and picked our top
30 restaurants.
So that's how we met.
And then we
discontinued talking.
And I think we want to go
out and eat Korean food.
Pretty much I was, hey, you
wanna grab some galbijjim
and we went.
And the other
question was about--
HILLARY: It was
about your influences
and your personal story and
the influences that really
comes through in your cooking.
DEUKI HONG: I started
cooking pretty young.
Overall, my whole life,
I'm really blessed
with a lot of-- I have a lot of
really cool people in my life.
A lot of good people.
That turned into really
cool opportunities.
I played baseball growing up.
My baseball coach was
partners with Drew Nieporent,
who is the guy who is head
of Myriad Restaurant Group.
Who'd started Nobu and that
whole-- they're like icons.
And obviously, I
don't know that.
He was like, if you like
restaurants, come on in.
So I did.
I literally just, every day,
starting from that point,
I worked for Chef Aaron
Sanchez, he's on TV now
and does his thing.
But yeah, after that, every
day after high school,
class would end, bus,
subway, into the restaurant.
So it was great.
And there was just more like,
I just love the restaurant.
Like I'm not one of those
guys that's like, oh
my gosh, like cucumbers.
Hey Chef.
MATT RODBARD: Chef
just walked in.
DEUKI HONG: Japchae
was on tonight.
MATT RODBARD: Yeah, the japchae
in the cafeteria was so good.
The chef just walked
in from Google.
DEUKI HONG: He's awesome.
Thank you so much.
Yeah That was kind of it.
Chef was like, you
need formal training.
I was like, I disagree.
I'll just stick with
you for my life.
And I went to culinary school.
I met Chef David Chang.
We both worked for DC.
Hopefully he never sees
this because I fear him.
I love him at the
same exact time.
MATT RODBARD: Love and
fear your older brother.
DEUKI HONG: But yeah, that
was my Momofuku experience.
And then I did the whole fine
dining route with Jean-Georges.
I just have so many like-- if
I had control of where I was
or what people to
meet, I don't think I
would have planned it that way.
But yeah, all my experiences
were really unique.
I'm influenced by all the
people that I worked with.
Forget if you're David
Chang's or the Jean-Georges
of the world.
Or if you're-- you know I
have 21 guys underneath me
in my kitchen and they
inspire me just as much.
It's all about people for me.
I don't go crazy over a cucumber
or like heirloom tomatoes.
They're great and
they're delicious,
but it's got to bigger
than that, I feel like.
HILLARY: So one of the things
you talk about in the book,
in the intro, is about this
idea that a lot of Korean food
happens in the home.
That it's very much a
home-oriented cuisine.
And I remember like
Matt, in your intro,
you'd go to restaurants
and you'd be like texting,
not how [KOREAN] made it.
You know, which is
Korean for grandma.
MATT RODBARD: That
was the kicker.
HILLARY: Yeah.
And seems like
attention to me, to make
a cookbook about
Korean food based
in the restaurant world, when
maybe it's more home-oriented.
And I'd love to hear
a little bit more
about how you navigated
that question in terms
of what recipes to include,
how to create them.
MATT RODBARD: I'll
take the first part,
which is the difference in home
cooking and restaurant cooking.
And a lot of times-- I
mean I think home cooking
is the best when it
comes to anything.
Like if you're making
at home, it's fantastic.
You're actually putting
it together yourself.
You're going through
that process,
be it painful or wonderful
or somewhere in between.
And you're serving your
family and your friends food.
That's a magical thing.
So I think home cooking
is the best to be honest.
Can we get there every night.
Of course not.
But for Korean food in
particular, a lot of times
the restaurants-- you
know they're not doing it
for the food and only the food.
They're doing it for
a variety of things.
Mostly it's to make money.
You know, Korean
Americans immigrated here
starting in the '50s and '60s
and a big chunk in the '70s.
And oftentimes
Koreans landed here
and there wasn't a lot
of job opportunities.
And one of the main jobs was
restaurants that they could do.
And oftentimes they
had to make money
and it was how they survived.
So are corners cut
in those situations.
In some cases, yes.
Is the food delicious,
yes. sometimes it's
not as good as it would be if
you're buying every component.
Or buying the best
gochujang you could.
Or buying the freshest produce.
So that's the one big
difference between the two.
I think folks need to
understand Korean food has
many different iterations
in the restaurant scene.
And you cover restaurants
a lot, so we can maybe
talk about that later.
HILLARY: Yeah, for sure.
MATT RODBARD: But the
other question for you
is for the actual
development of the recipes.
HILLARY: Yeah, for the
Whether you thought of it more
in terms of the way things come
together in a restaurant
versus the way
they come together at home.
DEUKI HONG:All right, so two
totally different mindsets.
I think a lot of the recipes
developed in the book-- half
are like from my
mom and half are
like-- there's no
standardization
in Korean cooking.
You ask like a Korean
old guy or like a mom,
they're like a little bit of
that, a little bit of this.
MATT RODBARD: There's
a word for it.
Son-mat, right?
Hand cooking.
DEUKI HONG: Son-mat.
MATT RODBARD: Son-mat.
Yeah, and It's like
hand cooking, right?
DEUKI HONG: Yeah.
Which is just a lazy way of,
I'm not going to measure it.
Like, truth.
I don't know.
And that was hard.
Because even when
we were cooking,
I would just adopt that.
So literally how we made
this book was, I cooked.
Matty was right next
to me with a laptop.
Hey, what did you put in there.
How much did you put in?
MATT RODBARD: Yeah
DEUKI HONG: Did you put that in?
Do I have to put that in?
MATT RODBARD: Yeah, or tell me.
Tell me now.
Like you're just like--
DEUKI HONG: Like a
recipe that takes me
fifteen minutes would take
like, literally two hours.
MATT RODBARD: We need numbers.
We're writing a cookbook,
we need numbers.
DEUKI HONG: Yeah,
that's like his thing.
Like people need this.
I was like, no, just
a little bit of that.
Because for me, you can't
measure salt. Or I don't know.
Like it's just, you
just do it to taste.
MATT RODBARD: Or
gochujang, even.
A major component.
HILLARY: Can you
explain what that is?
In case anybody--
MATT RODBARD:
Fermented pepper paste.
DEUKI HONG: Oh yeah, Korean
fermented chili paste.
So like, Korean
food is pretty much
based on the fermented
flavors, like jangs, right.
So doenjang, soybean paste.
Gochujang, which is
Korean chili paste.
It's kind of redundant
to say Korean.
And then soy sauce,
ganjang, right.
So those are kind of the three.
And then everything else
kind of stems off of that.
MATT RODBARD:
Branches off, yeah.
HILLARY: So another topic
that you guys bring up pretty
quickly in the intro to
the book is the importance
of tradition in Korean cooking.
And I was thinking about like
approaching this conversation
being at Google where
creativity is paramount.
Innovation is paramount.
And where, when you're working
with these traditional recipes,
was the room to bring
creativity and innovation,
both to the book or to your
work in the restaurant?
MATT RODBARD: Well when we were
working on the actual recipes,
to Deuki's credit,
he was able to cut
through a lot of the extra
steps needed for some
of these complicated recipes.
And you learn efficiency
in culinary school
and in running restaurants.
And we went through the
most efficient route.
And so that's a
creative approach.
Not every recipe is a
slow way of doing it.
That's one.
But I think secondly,
we have this section
in the book called Respect,
which shows how Korean food has
expanded beyond Koreatown, or
the physical Koreatown that we
know.
So the last chapter
is called Respect
and it has all these
guest recipes from chefs
throughout the country.
And when we went out and
talked to our friends
about the book
project, we weren't
looking for 20 versions
of the kimchi taco.
Or kimchi lasagna.
We wanted like real
Korean food done
in kind of an interesting
way, but from chefs
who knew Korean food.
So with that we've got like
Danny Bowen is doing this
really cool, in our
book, has a recipe
for a traditional Korean bone
broth called seolleongtang.
But what he does is he
gussies it up with some uni,
and he smokes brisket
and he puts it in there.
And smoked pastrami.
That's one example.
Sean Brock for example--
DEUKI HONG: It's a good recipe.
MATT RODBARD: It's a
really good recipe.
Sean Brock, who's a great
chef based in Nashville
and Charleston did a traditional
Korean pancake called pajeon,
but he did it with corn meal
and with lowcountry shrimp.
So I thought that was a really
cool way of understanding
Korean food but then being
creative with the recipe.
There's maybe 15 of those
recipes in the book.
And it just shows
time and again how
we chefs are thinking
about creating
flavors but articulating
it in their own way.
HILLARY: I think talking
about the respect
section of the book, which
again is the recipes contributed
by chefs who are not
necessarily known for cooking
Korean food-- with a
capital K and a capital
C-- I think there's
definitely room to grow,
but it's very fair to
say that there has never
been more interest in
America in Korean cuisine
than there is right now.
And I'm wondering why.
Like why Korean cuisine now?
MATT RODBARD: Oh.
DEUKI HONG: I don't know.
MATT RODBARD: Yeah.
DEUKI HONG: This is just--
we talked to a lot of chefs.
And we travelled.
The element of this
book-- it kind of
lends itself well to travel.
And I've been
blessed enough to be
in some of these
like top kitchens
and I'd like stay
there for a day
and like pick the chefs brain.
And we're talking about
like when we're in DC
and I'm with Eric-Bruner Yang.
These guys are like
the city icons.
Or like in charge of the food
movement in their cities.
And I asked them.
But you realize like
this is what they eat.
Like they're not eating like--
MATT RODBARD: French food.
DEUKI HONG: Sean
Brock isn't eating
like chicken and waffles.
Like country whatever.
He's eating Korean food and
he's like fermenting kimchi.
And you just appreciate
like this is going on.
Just nobody-- I don't
want to say nobody
cared, but like nobody
thought to ask that question.
Like what do you eat outside
of-- you just think like,
oh Eric Ripert, he probably eats
like very fancy French seafood
of some sort.
Probably cooks himself
the most perfect fish--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DEUKI HONG: But he's
eating Korean food.
He's eating Korean like,
Buddhist temple cuisine.
And you know you're
just like, oh, this
is like kind of awesome.
And for me, the respect
chapter, as a kid in the game,
it's freaking awesome.
It's like being a
basketball player
and then having
LeBron and Curry,
because we're in Curryland,
signing your yearbook, right?
Congrats on y'all, by the way.
Kobe by the way.
So it's like for me,
I'm just like, what, why
is he in the book?
Like not in a bad way.
Like Eric Ripert, Danny
Bowien, all these people
like we get to call now
because we're like, chef,
can I talk to you
about Korean food?
MATT RODBARD: Stu
Brioza, he's in the book
and he has a really cool
dish with yuba and house-made
kimchi.
DEUKI HONG: Such an incredible
meal yesterday at Statebird's.
MATT RODBARD: Yeah and he's
cooking with kimchi there
and cooking with
inspiration and adventure.
But I will add too, that
where Korean food is
right now in the restaurant
world nationally,
there's a lot of
Korean-American chefs like Deuki
who are cooking the foods
that they grew up on.
Folks like Beverly
Kim in Chicago.
Edward Lee in
Louisville, Kentucky.
And Edward Kim in Mott
Street in Chicago.
These are great examples.
There's many of
them who are cooking
these traditional flavors.
Chefs who maybe came from more
of a traditional background,
like a French background or
a fancy Italian background,
and they're actually
rediscovering
their own internal
recipe book but then
presenting them to the public
in kind of an uncompromised way.
And that's super exciting to be
seeing these traditional dishes
come to life.
HILLARY: I want to talk a little
bit about flavor with that too.
Because one of the
things that I've
been wondering about
as I've been thinking
more about Korean food and
why there's this uptick is
I definitely think there's
a little bit of a chicken
and egg.
Where it's like
well, chefs love it.
And they're telling
people, you know.
And that's why
customers love it.
But I also think that
one of the-- and you
talk about this so
much in the book--
a real pillar of
Korean cooking is
fermentation and the
process of fermentation
and then the flavors that
arise from fermentation
really carries the food.
And sort of America's
interest in fermented foods
is really on the rise right.
So for me, that was
sort of a through line
that I've been seeing
and thinking about it
as I read the book.
And as I'm thinking about why
chefs who don't necessarily
have a Korean background
or even a background
cooking that kind of
food or maybe dabbling.
Is America's palate expanding?
MATT RODBARD: I'll say that
just that Asian food in general
is expanding.
And Americans love these Eastern
Asian flavors, soy sauce,
fermented jangs,
be it Korean jangs
or Chinese fermented pastes.
You know, noodles from
Asia, ramen's kicked it off,
but now lots of pho--
you're seeing these flavors.
These sours, these very
like Asian flavors.
Fish sauce for example.
You're seeing fish
sauce everywhere.
You're seeing fish sauce
on brussels sprouts.
I mean brussels
sprouts aren't part
of the Asian like
vegetable category.
So I think you're just
seeing the American palate
is changing.
I mean, you see it in your
restaurant too, right?
DEUKI HONG: Yeah, I mean it
started for me in '09 when I
was working at JG and--
MATT RODBARD: Jean-Georges.
DEUKI HONG: Jean-Georges, sorry.
And the chef, their corporate
chef there, Chef Greg Brannon--
his palate is like, it's-- it's
just I've met so many people
that are like the
masters of like--
Serpico is like the guy--
HILLARY: Who's also going to
open a Korean Small Plates.
DEUKI HONG: He is.
MATT RODBARD: Oh yeah.
HILLARY: In Philadelphia,
for his second Philadelphia
restaurant.
MATT RODBARD: That's
another good one, yeah.
Sorry,
HILLARY: We're talking
about Peter Serpico, who
is a long-time Lieutenant in
David Chang's Momofuku empire
and is now a restaurant owner
and operator in Philadelphia.
DEUKI HONG: He's like a fish.
Like, you watch the guy break
down fish and you're just like,
I could watch this all day.
And I'm working right
next to these guys.
I was with Chef Greg and I
made him some Korean dish
for family meal.
And then he said the same thing.
He's like, I don't
understand why--
and this is seven
years ago-- isn't
Korean food-- like every
flavor profile of Korean food--
it hits what Americans like.
Sweet, savory, spicy.
And I said, I was like, chef,
I don't know, I'm just a kid.
I don't know.
But I understand it more
and more now because there's
nothing crazy about it.
We're not doing anything crazy.
The food existed for a while.
I just go back to that
kind of fermentation flavor
and I just think it's
that extra layer of umami
where you can't fabricate it.
You can, I mean in MSG.
But you can't.
It's different.
When you taste a really good
doenjang, and you taste soup
that comes out of
that doenjang--
that took months to make.
That took time.
It's different than miso, which
is no knock on miso, just--
MATT RODBARD: They're different.
DEUKI HONG: They're
very different.
MATT RODBARD: Doenjang and miso.
DEUKI HONG: So don't say
doenjang is Korean miso.
MATT RODBARD: Please
don't say that.
They're very different.
DEUKI HONG: It's very different.
MATT RODBARD: Maybe
Google can erase that
from the Google search terms.
DEUKI HONG: It's
probably possible.
MATT RODBARD: Probably in this
room, somebody can do that.
But really they're
just not the same.
They're both great
but in their own ways.
DEUKI HONG: I just
like this actually.
I don't know what it is.
It's the food that I eat.
The only reason I
cook Korean food
is not because I'm like
an ambassador for Korean.
Sadly, to say it-- I
probably shouldn't say this--
I don't care about that stuff.
I love eating Korean food.
Like I stopped cooking food
that I don't like eating
I think after JG.
After Jean-Georges, sorry.
Just because I
was all right, I'm
going to cook food that I like.
I generally like
eating Korean food.
MATT RODBARD: Question
in the audience.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DEUKI HONG: Go for it mama.
HILLARY: Do it.
DEUKI HONG: We're good.
It's like Friends.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DEUKI HONG: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: So, it also,
it crossed my mind,
because Korean food--
HILLARY: She's
bringing up the idea
that part of this
why Korean food now
is that the generation of chefs
coming up, people like Deuki,
have the language skills,
need the cultural savvy
to navigate things like
marketing, like press, like how
to word a menu to get
people in the door.
With your restaurant
Deuki, who comes to eat?
Who's coming to eat your food.
DEUKI HONG: White people.
Naw, I'm just joking.
No, I mean even going
back onto that, its right.
Our parents' generation
wasn't-- like they don't care
if a Michelin guy comes in
or you coming in or an editor
coming in.
It was really a for us,
by us kind of mentality.
We made Korean food and we
built Korean restaurants
because we missed
what he ate at home.
Or my parents missed at home.
They don't care about stars or
they don't care about whatnot.
For us, I think you're
completely right.
I completely agree.
Like for us now, our
mentality is like, oh dude,
this is really good, let's
tell our white friend about it.
Let's tell my Hispanic
friend about it.
Because we're able to.
MATT RODBARD: We write about
the KBF, the Korean best friend
that a lot of people have.
They have that one Korean
individual in their life
who tells them where to go.
And it's wonderful.
DEUKI HONG: You have
one, that Matty.
MATT RODBARD: I have one
here and another one--
DEUKI HONG: It's not me.
I didn't see my
name in your intro.
I'm just saying.
MATT RODBARD: Yeah, I've
got a very good friend
who lives in Oakland, who was
my gateway to Korean food.
But I think everyone has
that and it's so beautiful
to go to a restaurant to have
your Korean best friend show
you all the dishes.
Not just the barbecue but order
of like kalbijjim or something
cool like that.
DEUKI HONG: Sorry, who
comes to my restaurant.
A lot of people come
to the restaurant.
And that's crazy because we
serve a lot of people a day.
And y'all know in the back how
much because they serve Google.
But we do those kind of numbers.
Like I'm not used to it.
The biggest restaurant
I've worked for was I
think, it was Momofuku,
it was the noodle bar.
HILLARY: You mean
by just volume?
DEUKI HONG: Yeah,
it was just lines.
And it's like one of
those good worries.
Like, why are you complaining
about people lining up
at your restaurant.
But it's kind of like, for me
I don't need to fill a quota.
You know if we're
feeding 100 people,
I want it to be a damn
good meal, you know.
But I think it's
harder to control
when you get to the 600.
And on the weekends, like 900.
MATT RODBARD: And
to your credit,
when you go to Kang Ho Dong
Baekjeong, his restaurant
in New York, you're having
doenjang jigae, which is
the fermented bean paste stew.
And it's like the
best in the city.
And he's doing it
for 900 a night.
And it's crazy to do that.
That volume.
I mean it's really,
really impressive.
DEUKI HONG: I mean, it's not
easy and we want to cut it.
Like we were even talking
about like, should be like stop
accepting reservations.
And stop accepting people
at a certain amount
just to like quality,
like how ramen shops do.
But we realized
that we don't care.
We're just like,
just serve everybody.
HILLARY: Like make it work.
DEUKI HONG: Yeah, make it work.
Exactly.
Like forget that.
Just make it work.
But a lot of
awesome people come.
I mean, we've been
embraced by the industry.
And I think that's
our biggest-- I
cook for-- like I can't
read-- the last time I clicked
into Yelp and read our or
any restaurant that I've
worked at review was a
really long time ago.
I just don't do it.
I don't know of many
industry people do it.
I cook for the industry people.
And I don't know if
that's right or wrong.
I don't care.
I cook for chefs.
I cook for industry.
I love industry people.
Not that I don't care
about anybody else.
It's that I focus on them.
I use that expensive
cut of meat because I'm
sure chef is going to come and
he deserves a nice cut of meat.
I'm not going to go use
that cheaper cut to save
a little bit here because
I feel like there's
this fraternity and this
camaraderie where I trust you,
you trust me type of deal.
Where I trust you enough
and I go to your restaurant
and there's that element.
But I feel like I cook for
chefs in New York City.
HILLARY: So that's really
a question about audience.
And who your audience is and
which part of your audience
you are focusing on.
How did you guys imagine
the audience for the book?
And who were you writing for?
MATT RODBARD: Great question.
So I think we were looking to
capture a few audiences first
and foremost Korean-Americans.
I think there's a lot of
Korean-Americans out there
who know the dishes but
don't know how to make them
but are dabbling into food.
I think you're seeing
a lot of young folks
who are you subscribing
to Blue Apron
or maybe buying a cookbook and
experimenting with cooking.
But a lot of Korean-Americans
have the books
that tell you how to make it.
So that was one audience.
But then the bigger audience
was fans of Asian food.
Like people who line up
for the ramen burger.
Or go down to San Gabriel
Valley in Los Angeles
or out to San Jose to have the
Vietnamese food or whatever.
You know, those folks,
whoever they may be,
we're writing that book
for them because we
want them to see that Korean
food has a lot of personality
and there's a lot of
intricacies there.
And we did the work.
We went through all these
dishes and told the stories
in the head notes.
And so it's for that audience.
And then I don't know, who else?
DEUKI HONG: I just like
did it to our friends.
We don't reach like--
I shouldn't say that,
I have to-- we're not like
one of these beautiful,
illustrious--
MATT RODBARD: Domnique Crenn's
book, which is an amazing.
HILLARY: This is not
a coffee table book.
It's a book that can get dirty.
MATT RODBARD: It's a bit
of a nightstand book,
I'd like to say.
You can actually read it.
HILLARY: It's a good read.
And it's not too precious.
So I feel like you
can spill on it.
DEUKI HONG: I feel
like the language
we use-- at least audience,
I wasn't like let's target
like 25 to 35.
The language, to Matt's
credit-- and I love the way
he writes too.
It's like talking
to your friend.
You're not going
to see that book.
It's not like some
encyclopedia, like a formal--
there's a bit of salty
language in there.
MATT RODBARD: One
reviewer on Amazon--
DEUKI HONG: So we
got an Amazon review.
She e-mailed us.
She was like a mother
in the middle America.
And we're just grateful that
somebody in middle America
heard about us.
MATT RODBARD: And
I'm from Michigan.
From Middle America too.
DEUKI HONG: But she
has like ten kids.
And she was like,
oh, I love your book.
I love your recipes.
But I'm so disappointed
in you Deuki.
You're using salty language.
And I was like,
what is going on.
MATT RODBARD: What is going on.
DEUKI HONG: Like, Matty
did you swear on my behalf?
MATT RODBARD: And
Deuki literally
went through it
every single page
to see where the
salty language was.
But really, what happened was
that's David Chang's quote.
DEUKI HONG: So
what happened was,
there's literally four
pages in our whole book.
And I can name you those
pages, 87, 163, 164, and 202
or something like that.
And two of those pages is the
interview with Chef Chang.
And like you can't
filter that guy.
So I think she might have
confused the two Asians.
And like, oh that's
probably him.
So we don't blame you, Abby.
She bought the
book and you know,
she was like very
disappointed in us.
I was really sad
for the whole day.
I was like, oh man.
MATT RODBARD: I know.
DEUKI HONG: There's a
family in middle America
that thinks I'm really horrible.
MATT RODBARD: Voice is really
important though with writing.
And I think we captured it.
And thank you for the praise,
but it's really both of us.
It's me interviewing
Deuki and recording it,
and then transcribing it,
and having that in there.
Or just us being together a lot.
It's almost like osmosis, it
comes between, into my brain
and into yours.
And we express ourselves in the
book truthfully and honestly.
And that's hard to do
in a lot of writing.
And credit to our
editor for not--
DEUKI HONG: Editing it out.
Not cleaning up anything.
MATT RODBARD: Yeah.
DEUKI HONG: It's like
if you called us.
We talk as if, just call us.
And I think even in the
book, we're like yo,
just reach us out on social.
It's a chill book.
We're not, I'm not--
HILLARY: You guys give you
twitter handles in the book?
MATT RODBARD: Chill book.
DEUKI HONG: You know,
we're just like chill.
It's great, even
now on Instagram.
People like made something from
the book and they'll tag us
and then we'll see it.
It's like still surreal.
Like we had the
japchae today in the--
MATT RODBARD: Google cafeteria.
AUDIENCE: Conscious Cafe.
DEUKI HONG: What cafe?
MATT RODBARD: In the
Conscious Cafe while
we were in San Francisco.
And it was great.
It was excellent.
DEUKI HONG: It's
just so surreal.
It's like oh my gosh.
It's like people are--
MATT RODBARD:
Cooking Korean food.
DEUKI HONG: First of all,
somebody made something
from this book.
And it's being served to y'all.
MATT RODBARD: It's cool.
DEUKI HONG: It's just
one of those things
where it will click tomorrow.
MATT RODBARD: Any questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering
if you guys saw
a reaction from the
Korean culinary industry?
HILLARY: So the question
must have you guys
seen a reaction from Korea?
From the Korean
culinary industry?
MATT RODBARD: Well I've
been to Korea a few times.
There aren't a lot of
books sold in Korea,
so that I don't think
the book is quite--
DEUKI HONG: That is so bad,
like we don't read books.
MATT RODBARD: Well,
no but-- sorry,
there aren't a lot of cookbooks.
I thought it was clear,
but it wasn't clear.
There aren't a lot of
cookbooks sold in Korea.
It's not a big industry.
So I'm not sure
if people in Korea
are actually seeing
what we're doing.
But I will say this about
the Korean industry.
It's exciting.
Seoul is a crazy
restaurant town.
And not just the
traditional cooking
which you'll find anything
and everything in Seoul
and it's amazing.
And I think media is going to
really start to pay attention
to the way that they've
looked at Tokyo 10 years ago
when Bourdain went there.
And everyone
followed pretty much.
Korea is the next
place because Bourdain
went there and everyone's
going to follow, mark my words.
But on the higher end,
on the higher echelon,
there's really exciting places.
One's Mingles in Seoul.
That chef is doing
such incredible work.
And I hope that I can write
about him soon and kind of
bring his story to the masses.
But it's hard to say.
I'd like to hope that people
in Korea are reading the book
and they're seeing how
Americans are interpreting
traditional Korean food.
But I think the
jury is still out.
DEUKI HONG: And I
think or Koreans
are-- we don't know how
Korea feels about us.
I mean, I think
Koreans are the biggest
supporters of-- like if
I see anything Korean,
like I'll just go to
just check it out.
In that same respect, I
think Koreans are the biggest
haters of Koreans also.
They are so critical.
Like chill out.
MATT RODBARD: Toughest critics.
I see you.
DEUKI HONG: I am.
I'm guilty of it too.
It's like, no man,
no, this is not good.
But like it's just like
one of those things
where they'll support you just
because you're doing something
for their culture.
And you're doing something.
And hopefully that
that's how they view it.
For us, we don't say that
this is like just going back
on authenticity.
And we don't say that this is
some authentic Korean grandma
cooking.
And God, it's so not.
And we have a recipe in
there with a crap ton
of bacon and butter.
Kimchi
MATT RODBARD: Fried rice.
DEUKI HONG: She'd throw it
out the window right away.
But we don't know
how Koreans feel.
I hope that they like it.
If they don't, great.
If they do, great.
AUDIENCE: Koreans are very
difficult to procure and--
DEUKI HONG: Yeah, that's a
great, that's an incredible--
HILLARY: So this was a question
about whether you guys have
done any experimentation
with recipes
with replacing it
maybe difficult to get
Korean ingredients with
perhaps more local ingredients.
DEUKI HONG: I mean,
personally for me,
so just going back
on that authenticity,
like I can't cook
Korean Korean food.
Because I'm in New York.
The city of New York.
LA Korean food and New York
Korean food taste different.
Imagine how it is in
Korea and New York.
Or LA and Korea.
So I just started
making doenjang, right?
But I got it from Korea, because
somebody like smuggled it in.
MATT RODBARD: Block you
off the record, watch.
DEUKI HONG: Totally
shouldn't have said that.
But it's just like, I just
want to see the process of it.
And then I can see how the
soybean-- I mean who knows.
Like New York has awesome
local product too.
I mean, you guys
are in California.
So it's like chefs
are kind of cheating.
Of course you're
making good food.
You guys put some salt
and the olive oil on it
and it tastes delicious.
But for us, I want
to start doing that.
And that's such a great point,
because that's important,
right?
Because I don't want to mimic.
I can't even mimic,
even if I wanted to.
What they do in Korea
in their terroir, right?
And I feel like you're
going to get distinctively
Californian Korean food.
Distinctively New
York Korean food.
MATT RODBARD: One big
difference too is beef.
You know beef
barbecue for example
is different here
than it is in Korea.
I mean beef in Korea is
incredibly expensive.
There isn't a lot of
land to raise cattle
so it is expensive.
They get beef from
places like China.
Pork is less expensive
but it's expensive.
And they get pork
from Argentina.
They ship it all
the way to Korea.
So in America beef is cheap.
So you're seeing Korean barbecue
restaurants proliferate here
and not so much in Korea.
Of course, there are barbecue
restaurants in Korea,
but it's not as prevalent.
Korea is a peninsula.
There is 1,500 miles
of coastline in Korea.
And so with that,
seafood is essential.
It's fundamental in the diet.
And that's different here.
Here it's beef, it's pork,
it's barbecue, it's grilling,
it's bibimbap.
It's a lot more beef
and pork driven.
So that's a big difference
between the two.
HILLARY: I thought I saw
another hand back there as well.
No I think that's
absolutely right.
And I don't want to
speak for chefs when
I have a chef sitting
next to me but you
know there's only so many
tools that a chef works with.
You have temperature, you
have flavor, you have texture.
That's like, that's
what you have, you know?
I think your point that
myriad possibilities that
exist within Korean cooking is,
I think, a big driver of what's
attracting American chefs
without Korean cooking
or heritage backgrounds to it.
I think that's 100% true.
That's something you guys
cover in the book, actually.
MATT RODBARD: Yeah.
But also the health comment
is really interesting to me
because it is a really big
part of the Korean diet.
Really the East Asian diet.
It's low impact and high flavor.
And I mean that's our next
book, Low Impact, High Flavor.
HILLARY: 101 Korean
Recipes for Your Health.
MATT RODBARD: Right.
Exactly.
We could sell some books.
But really, it's dairy
free, pretty much,
except for a few things.
It's gluten free, pretty much,
for except for a few things.
And incredibly delicious.
And the fermented element of it
just draws out so much flavor
and it really makes
protein less important.
Namul, seasoned vegetables too.
Not fermented vegetables,
seasoned vegetables
are a huge part
of the Korean diet
and those are
incredibly healthy.
Also you just look at the
Korean population in America
and in Korea.
It's very healthy population,
except for all the drinking.
HILLARY: Which is what I
was going to transition to.
Because there's a whole section
in the cookbook about drinking
food.
And why does that
get it's own section?
DEUKI HONG: It needs
its own section.
MATT RODBARD: It does
need its own section
and we give it the space.
What do you want to say.
I mean you own a
restaurant in Koreatown
that is open until literally
6:00 AM on Saturday.
DEUKI HONG: No, it's not good.
MATT RODBARD: There's nothing
good that happens at that time.
DEUKI HONG: I mean it's true.
It's just there's nothing
right about that in any city.
We drink a lot.
I don't know.
It's like not binge-drinking
though, like stupid college
kids in America.
MATT RODBARD: It's different
DEUKI HONG: It's like grown
adults in like business attire
and they complain.
MATT RODBARD: Drinking
like stupid college kids.
DEUKI HONG: Yeah like stupid
college kids in America.
But I feel like--
Asians are, as you
can tell I'm very socially
awkward, so they need alcohol
to break it.
Or I don't really know
the science behind it.
Soju is cheaper
than water there.
It's like, bro.
MATT RODBARD: And soju is
the traditional spirit.
It's a distilled rice spirit.
DEUKI HONG: And it was kind
of like, OK, let's drink.
I don't know.
But it's not like we're
like cocktail mixologists.
We're just very simple--
HILLARY: Can you tell
me a little bit more
specifically about the food
and sort of the relationship
of food and drinking?
MATT RODBARD: Well there's a
great harmony between drinking
and eating in Korea.
So you're not just going to
the bar and having 16 shots.
You're having a full spread,
banchan, the plates that
arrive before the meal arrive.
And then you have
a really hot soup.
And maybe have some
mackerel, I mean
there's like all these
dishes that are specifically
for drinking.
And it's kind of meant to
prolong the drinking session,
so to speak, when you're
out with your boss,
or you're out with your
friends, or you're out
with your peer circle.
So you can go out to two
or three of these pochas
and then maybe a restaurant
and maybe a karaoke.
You have to eat to prolong it
to power yourself through it.
So we have a spicy
clam soup, which
is like a really
classic pocha dish.
It's just when you've
kind of had a few too many
and you start drinking that
warm fish stock and peppers
and it's just really light.
And it's just rejuvenating.
DEUKI HONG: It's
essentially like
what happens at our
restaurant or what
I've seen in the past
few years is that--
and usually like a
K-town run, I guess,
it's just so bad--
You eat dinner.
They'll eat dinner-- and
I've seen it multiple times,
it's not like an
occurrence like, oh
my gosh, that never happens.
They'll eat dinner at our
place, go out, drink, you know,
pre-game or whatever.
And then they'll hit the clubs.
Preferably Circle,
New York City,
hottest Asian nightclub
in New York City.
HILLARY: Hot tip.
DEUKI HONG: And then they'll
come back to the restaurant.
So literally, I'm like bro,
I saw you four hours ago.
What are you doing?
And you know, they're
like wasted at this time.
But in every element of
their stop, they're drinking.
Sometimes with food.
Sometimes without food.
But that relationship.
You know, they'll
go to like a pocha,
where it's like pretty
much a night market.
Not necessarily a gastropub.
It's just like
really good stews.
A lot of salty, savory dishes.
MATT RODBARD: Fried chicken too.
DEUKI HONG: Yeah.
That goes along with a lot
of the soju and makgeolli.
There's drinking
involved in a lot of it.
I don't know why because
Koreans are like,
our bodies are not
built to drink.
Asians aren't built to drink.
I think there's like
a science behind that.
You guys are smart.
Y'all look it up somewhere.
But we do.
And it's a big part
of our culture.
HILLARY: I know our
time is winding down,
so I have some lightning
round questions for you.
So I'm going to ask
them fast, you're
going to answer them fast.
MATT RODBARD: Okay.
HILLARY: For novice
and beginner cooks,
where should they
start in your cookbook.
MATT RODBARD: I like the
one pot doenjangjigae.
I like making that
bean paste soup.
DEUKI HONG: Make
the quick kimchis.
MATT RODBARD: Quick kimchis?
DEUKI HONG: Yeah.
HILLARY: And for those
who are just less familiar
with Korean food in
general, how would
you suggest they approach
a Korean restaurant menu?
MATT RODBARD: For me,
ask a lot of questions.
You just go in and go in with
maybe a little bit of a plan
but like I'm going
to have a soup,
I'm going to have
a barbecue, I'm
going to have maybe a pancake.
But start asking questions.
It's so important.
DEUKI HONG: I don't
think you're going to get
any answers from a Korean.
Whatever.
I mean, pick something.
Hopefully it tastes good.
Roll a dice.
What do you want me to say?
HILLARY: Do you have
any recommendations
for good Korean food in San
Francisco or is the answer
get on a plane and go to LA?
MATT RODBARD: It's a very--
San Francisco doesn't
have an abundance of
Korean restaurants compared
to other cities,
like Los Angeles.
But honestly--
DEUKI HONG: Sorry,
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MATT RODBARD: So I interviewed
in the book, I went to--
AUDIENCE: When are you
going to open up one here?
MATT RODBARD: This crowd wow.
We felt the--
HILLARY: Serious.
Serious.
Someone just asked when
you're going to open here.
DEUKI HONG: If the right
opportunity-- I mean--
AUDIENCE: So the
Chinese food went there,
you need to come here.
MATT RODBARD: Yeah,
I like that idea.
DEUKI HONG: Chef Danny
is a good friend.
And Chef Corey.
MATT RODBARD: Let's
talk about Corey Lee.
HILLARY: Oh yeah, let do that.
Let's talk about Corey Lee.
He's the chef of benu.
He just got his
third Michelin star.
MATT RODBARD: Korean-Americans.
DEUKI HONG: I love Corey Lee.
That's all I have to say
about Chef Corey Lee.
I admire that man.
I worship the ground
that he walks on.
To put it lightly
HILLARY: I think for just
a little more background,
the food that he's doing at
benu-- sort of in the same way
that you see chefs of
Korean-American heritage
in America-- they wouldn't
say like, no I'm not
cooking Korean food, I'm
cooking American food.
And for me, American food means
flavors from my childhood.
Ingredients from where I live.
And techniques that
I grew up using.
So somebody like a
David Chang for example,
you feel like he's
in conversation
with what Corey Lee is doing.
DEUKI HONG: That's great point.
HILLARY: And I think Dave
brought up Corey in your book
in that interview.
MATT RODBARD: Oh I think he has
a similar opinion that Deuki
has that Corey's doing.
DEUKI HONG: I mean
not that intense.
MATT RODBARD: Not that intense.
But he's in a very
important figure
in talking about
Korean food in America.
And he's here in San Francisco.
I like Brother's Barbecue.
That's another place.
I think that's fantastic.
HILLARY: But I have to say
this one thing about benu.
They do this dish.
When it arrives at your
table, it's teeny tiny.
And it's this like
see through red shell
on top of which
you see an oyster.
And you bite it and you're like,
I've had these flavors before.
This is like, what is this.
Well it turns out
see through shell
somehow was made of kimchi.
And there was also
pork in there.
And it's like this
little baby bossam bite.
But you know, it's magical.
DEUKI HONG: Chef Corey
Lee, ladies and gentlemen.
Corey Lee.
I wasn't fortunate enough.
I had to save about
seven paychecks.
HILLARY: I went with my brother.
He's a lawyer.
MATT RODBARD: That's true.
But really like the
classic flavors being
done in an interesting way.
I think that's really the future
of Korean food in America.
You're going to see
it time and again.
It's just the
traditional flavors.
Not fusion.
Not like kimchi grilled cheese.
It's not that.
DEUKI HONG: Hating on the
taco and the grilled cheese.
MATT RODBARD: Sorry.
HILLARY: So yes
in San Francisco,
we were saying-- one
answer to that question
of where can you find Korean
flavor in San Francisco is at
benu, if you're fortunate
enough to be able to go.
And then you were saying
Brother's Barbecue.
MATT RODBARD: Yeah, and
that's in Richmond, right?
It's a good spot.
I went there--
DEUKI HONG: We know no
places in San Francisco.
We're like trying to
pull to you, we're like--
MATT RODBARD: We didn't
spend too much time eating
at Korean restaurants here.
LA was such an important
part, we went there mostly.
But I had a really good chance
to visit with Adam Johnson,
who wrote Orphan Master's Son,
who won a Pulitzer in 2013,
and we had a meal at Brother's.
And I thought it was great.
They make their own
time doenjang there
and it's charcoal BBQ.
It's a good one.
FEMALE SPEAKER: You could ask
your audience where they do.
MATT RODBARD: Yeah,
where do you guys go?
HILLARY: Yeah, where
are you guys eating?
DEUKI HONG: Why are
we-- we're New Yorkers.
MATT RODBARD: San Jose?
DEUKI HONG: That's not SF, girl.
MATT RODBARD: What's that?
Namu?
DEUKI HONG: Oh, Namu Gaji.
No, that's not here.
Is that here?
HILLARY: Yeah, that's
like Dolores Park.
MATT RODBARD: Yeah.
I think in two years too,
a bunch of other places
are going to open,
I would imagine.
HILLARY: Yeah,
the Namu Gaji team
is opening a new
restaurant, I believe
on Divisadero, that's
going to be like just
focused on stonepot cooking.
DEUKI HONG: She's
got the inside scoop.
MATT RODBARD: That's great.
HILLARY: Eater.com.
DEUKI HONG: Eater.
MATT RODBARD: Yeah,
definite shout out to Eater.
There's a question.
What do we think
about Japanese food?
DEUKI HONG: Sick of Japanese--
HILLARY: What was the question?
What do you think
of Japanese food?
MATT RODBARD: They're
very different.
I've been to Japan a few times
and I think the world of it.
It's a beautiful culture.
They're different.
There is a lot of
geopolitical elements
between Korea and Japan too
that we could talk at Google
another time about.
DEUKI HONG: No, I agree,
it's very different.
I think their technicians.
When I see them making rice for
three years or whatever it is.
You're dealing with--
especially [INAUDIBLE]
go on sushi like-- you're
dealing with two or three
ingredients.
So you're not masking anything.
It's either it's how
you cook the fish that
affects the texture.
And that affects the taste
of it and the experience
that you get.
And how you season your rice.
So all of that,
like for me, it's
like when I see
less ingredients,
that means a lot of technique.
It has to be a give, right.
So I respect that
cuisine so much.
I think in a lot of what I do
comes from Japanese cuisine
too.
And that's OK.
MATT RODBARD: Got a shout-out
to a really great book
about Japanese food
called Rice, Noodle, Fish.
HILLARY: Oh it's so good.
You have to read it.
MATT RODBARD: Done
by Bourdain Books,
Matt Goulding's the author.
Highly recommend it.
It's fantastic.
HILLARY: I had a very
flippant thought which
is another tie that I
see between Japanese
and Korean food in America
is that both are better in LA
than in almost any
other location.
Literally almost any
other American city.
DEUKI HONG: SF is good.
MATT RODBARD: Yeah
it is really good.
HILLARY: It's just, Los Angeles
as a culinary powerhouse
in our country has a few really
niche areas where they just
really excel.
And Japanese food
in LA is incredible.
Are there any other
audience questions
before we call it a day?
AUDIENCE: Favorite Korean dish.
MATT RODBARD: Oh great.
DEUKI HONG: Yeah,
let's shut it down.
MATT RODBARD: I like kalbijjim,
which is a braised short rib.
DEUKI HONG: He changes It
every interview that we do.
I just want you to know
that he had like gamjatang
like a couple of weeks ago.
MATT RODBARD: I know,
I had gamjatang.
We didn't really geek out about
Korean dishes in this panel.
DEUKI HONG: You did.
MATT RODBARD: OK.
Well, read the book.
There's a lot of
great dishes in there
and there's lots of cool
stories and yeah, that's mine.
That's mine today.
What about you?
DEUKI HONG: Daktoritang, it's
the first dish I ever made.
My mom makes it awesome.
She can't cook for life,
but she makes that.
HILLARY: I would say
mine is kimchi pancake.
MATT RODBARD:
Yeah, what's yours.
DEUKI HONG: Kimchi pancake
MATT RODBARD: Kimchi pancake.
And I want to thank Eater
for covering Korean food so
thoroughly and rigorously.
And you're a big part of it.
So thank you very much.
DEUKI HONG: Hillary
HILLARY: Thank you guys.